Nothing in life can prepare you for the
raw heat of a house on fire throwing an
arm up in front of his eyes and clasping
a handkerchief to his mouth Robert
chetford hacked up half of the contents
of his lungs glancing at the material he
saw that his phlegm was black poisoned
by the smoke a beam collapsed in front
of him sending a fresh wave of burning
air into his face so hot that it felt
like it was going to Scorch his ears off
he had to run he had to get out of the
house but he knew he couldn't his mother
was upstairs Robert barreled his way
through the Flames shouldering open
doors and stumbling along hallways the
air was so thick with smoke that he
could barely breathe so he collapsed to
the floor and started to crawl on his
stomach he reached the first step of the
grand staircase and started to he
himself up one at a time feeling the
heat of the house threatening to engulf
him more with every inch he climbed but
he hadn't made it more than five steps
before there was an enormous creaking
sound and the whole staircase collapsed
beneath him Sparks rushed up into the
air and swirled around the room Flames
licked at the walls all around him as
Robert looked around at the collapsed
staircase he thinking that it was
hopeless with tears streaming down his
cheeks he pushed himself forward and ran
out of the house the firemen swarmed
past him filling the building and
shouting to one another but Robert just
stood there staring up at the top floor
window on the other side of the glass
surrounded by billowing smoke he looked
up at his mother sitting as she always
did on her rocking chair utterly
motionless as the house burned around
her in an undisclosed facility in the
United States of America you will find
what may well be the lowest security
containment cell in the entire SCP
Foundation there is no heavily armored
door no bulletproof glass no machine
guns about to drop down from the ceiling
at any point in fact there's very little
in the way of containment at all they
often leave the door to the cell wide
open there is a window but on the other
side of it isn't a crowd of researchers
security guards and agents ready to
spring into action at a moment's notice
it just a normal double glazed window
that looks out across a Vista of fields
trees and a couple of power lines facing
the window is an old armchair in which
the concrete man sits
scp-014 he spends all of his day every
day staring out of the window this view
specifically was chosen because very
little changes in it night turns today
the trees change with the seasons and it
rains occasionally but there are no
roads no new buildings springing up
nothing to distinguish it from how it
looked in 1937 beside him is a small
table home to a record player in the
corner of the room there's an antique
set of shelves that house three dozen
old records all dated from the 1930s or
earlier all day every day the music
plays out of the old speaker every so
often as researchers walk up and down
the corridor if they hear that there
isn't any music playing the come into
the room and change the record over for
a new one the newest researchers check
in with scp-014 to see if he's okay he
rarely responds and so before long they
stop asking you would think therefore
that the concrete man is elderly
approaching the Twilight years of his
life but the man who sits there in his
chair staring out of the window and
listening to music from almost 100 years
ago appears to be just 30 years old
friends of Robert chetford reported a
noticeable change in his demeanor
following the fire and death of his
mother he had lost his father not long
before to a workplace accident William
chetford had been a construction worker
climbing up the girders of New York's
emerging Skyline pouring concrete and
piling bricks he had been working on a
new building one that was said to be the
tallest in the world called the Empire
State Building day after day he would
climb the cranes Teeter precariously
over the dizzying drops and he saw like
mistake and he would plummet hundreds of
feet often to the busy streets below
sure enough one day William chetford's
worst fears came to life it was walking
on a gangplank that wobbled and bent
with every step he took on his shoulders
was a metal bar with a bucket of
concrete dangled precariously from each
tip he walked this route every day but
clearly that day proved too much for the
wood to take the board splintered and
split beneath him plunging him down and
down through the scaffolding William
desperately reached out an arm and
managed to grasp the edge of a girder he
hung there helplessly staring up at his
colleagues high above him he cried out
for help and upon seeing him they began
to scramble down level by level to try
and rescue him he just needed to hang on
for a moment longer and they would
rescue him but one of them knocked over
a bucket of concrete William chetford
could do nothing but watch as the heavy
sludge slowly tumbled towards his face
he tried to dodge it but it was no you
the company told Mrs chetford that this
had been Williams Saving Grace that he
had been unconscious for the long fall
down to the streets below his fellow
workers knew that this wasn't the case
they heard his screams all the way down
Mrs chetford didn't believe any of it
they were lying all of them the company
his co-workers everybody she knew what
had really killed him it was the same
thing that was killing her slowly the
same thing that had been passed on to
their son concrete poisoning she'd
approached the Wall Street Journal New
York Times and any Outlet she could but
none of them were remotely interested in
the story there were chemicals in the
concrete it wasn't safe to use it never
had been she'd been working in nursing
homes and seen the effects of concrete
on construction workers they become
paralyzed unable to move spending so
many years breathing concrete air
letting it absorb into their skin their
bodies had slowly started to turn into
it she knew it she started to go crazy
pinning up news clippings medical
journals photographs Maps anything she
could find all over her walls her entire
bedroom she had red string hanging from
the walls and ceiling connecting to
every surface Robert watched helplessly
from the doorway unable to do anything
as he saw his mother steadily entering
into psychosis but the further her
paranoia went the less energy she seemed
to have for it weeks went by and her
manic fervor was replaced with lethargy
she got slower and slower in her
movements talked less and less at meal
times and began to sit down for extended
chunks of the day Robert assuming that
she was tired from grief did what he
could to help he carried an armchair up
to her room and placed it in the corner
by the window so that she could look out
over the world around her he thought she
was resting but it soon became apparent
that she wasn't really resting she was
withdrawing almost freezing over
desperate to try and get his mother to
read engage with the world Robert sat
down with her to try and understand all
of her conspiracy theories around his
father's death she explained slowly and
calmly that the concrete being used in
New York was poisoned cursed she didn't
know where it had been dug up from how
it had been mixed or who was behind it
but she was getting close maybe it was
the US government maybe it was the same
witches maybe it was God himself but she
knew her husband and she knew he
wouldn't have fallen that day he'd
walked across that plank thousands of
times without incident there was no way
he would have made that mistake Robert
tried to connect the dogs of what she
was saying did she really think that it
was the concrete that had killed his
father she said that it was and that the
same concrete is now killing her she
showed him her hands turned them over
front and back under the light for him
to inspect they looked just like normal
hands elderly wrinkled with deep veins
popping out but normal she scratched at
them and tried to feign pain for the
effects of her fingers look she said you
see that powder coming off of them
that's concrete powder but Robert didn't
see any of it the concrete man came to
the foundation's attention a couple
decades ago construction workers in New
York in the late 1990s were hard at work
clearing out the foundations for a new
skyscraper the site was built on top of
what used to be a residential block the
one Intrepid Builder soon discovered
Something That Shook him to his core
there was an old seller beneath where
the building used to be the lock on it
was Heavy thick with rust and had been
open for close to 70 years he and his
team managed to pry it open put on their
flashlights and went inside what they
found was a basement apartment still
sitting there beneath the rubble it was
a relic of its time thick dust covered
every surface
ugly wallpapers surrounded them and
ancient appliances covered with rust sat
in the kitchen it was almost like
walking through a haunted house the
builders joked about ghosts stalking
these corridors as they made their way
through until they reached the bedroom
sliding the door open they faced a man
sitting there staring at them from an
old armchair the four Burly Builders
screamed like little girls for a split
second then burst out laughing when they
realized that the man wasn't real he
must have been a wax work or something
he was sitting so perfectly still and
hadn't reacted at all to their presence
they went over to inspect what he was
made out of they tapped on his forehead
lifted his arms and dropped them and
were surprised at how convincing the
fake man was that was of course until he
politely asked them not to touch him
this time they really did scream like
girls running straight out of the
basement into a local police station
this basement apartment was where Robert
chetford moved following the fire in his
parents home and the death of his
paralyzed mother racked with guilt he
had never been quite able to process
what had happened to cause his mother's
mental state to deterior so rapidly by
the time she died she had been looking
at her hands and genuinely believed they
were made of concrete she would not move
she would not eat she would not sleep
for days she would just sit staring out
of her window he knew he should have
taken her to a doctor but they just
couldn't afford it maybe if he had this
would have all worked out differently
Robert would think about it hour after
hour he would sit down in the armchair
in the corner of his room and Ponder
what had happened it was difficult to
keep track of time living in the
basement there were no windows no
daylight at all but he didn't think he
had been sitting there for very long
when he noticed the skin on his hands
starting to turn gray without Panic he
slowly lifted his hands to his eyes and
inspected what was happening his fingers
down to about halfway through his palms
were dry and solid he could move them
just about but it took a normal effort
and he could see cracks running along
the back of the concrete when he did so
he decided not to he wouldn't say say he
felt calm exactly maybe disconnected he
didn't feel particularly hungry he
didn't feel particularly tired in fact
he didn't feel much at all his concrete
limbs were only a passing curiosity to
him as he sat in his chair very
occasionally he would get up to put on a
record on his record player then return
to his seat and stare at the wall that
would be every couple of months at most
the rest of the time he would just sit
there one day he noticed in a vague
corner of his mind that the ground was
shaking and dust was filling the room
The Ripping sound of dynamite and the
heavy Stone just above his head told him
that the apartment block towering over
him had fallen down and almost come
through his ceiling Robert just sat
there unconcerned another day some
indeterminate time later a group of
Builders came in dressed in Peculiar
futuristic clothing with bright yellow
hats and reflective vests they seemed
rather startled to see him though in
truth he had little care for seeing them
what did perturb him was when a group of
people claiming to be Agents from the
foundation came into his room and
carried him out he didn't like the noise
didn't like the change if he wanted to
move he would move not that he could of
course he was now entirely made of
concrete but that was beside the point
these people put him in the back of a
van and drove him across half of the
United States they wheeled him through
brightly lit rooms and into a disgusting
modern white box they had done the
courtesy of bringing his chair along and
found a new record player for him with a
whole selection of albums lining a shelf
on the wall he would have appreciated it
and said thank you to them but he didn't
really care he wasn't present at all
this was of course due to the fact that
he was made of concrete by this point
however once he was sat in his chair and
took in the sight in front of him Robert
chedford felt a dull Panic rising in his
chest they placed him at a window just
like he'd placed his dying mother in
front of a window he tried to clench his
jaw tried to move his hands tried to cry
out in fear and pain but he couldn't he
was paralyzed the smell of smoke filled
his chest choking him torturing him as
the memories of his burning household
raged in his mind he tried to scream he
tried to fight he tried to do anything
other than just sit there but it was far
too late for any of that good afternoon
Mr chetford the researcher said busying
herself and putting on another album for
him to listen to is there anything I can
do for you sir anything I can do to make
you more comfortable the concrete man
said nothing the researcher patted him
on the back of his hand made of concrete
indeed looks just like regular skin to
me Mr chetford I do wonder what's going
on inside that head of yours on her way
out of the room she glanced at his view
from the window beautiful weather
outside today isn't it scorching even
now go check out scp-011 sentient Civil
War Memorial and scp-650 startling
statue for more